my mission is super simple it's very  very much a the same as yours it's to  help you create a better life  and  selfishly my mission is that I wanted to  get off the road  I wanted to stop feeling so lonely  and I wanted to be able to  connect with people and share my life  and the things that I'm learning in a  much more personal and real-time way  that I can't do in an audiobook and I  can't do on a stage you know giving a  speech and I can't do in a 60 second  reel I wanted to go all in and I think  particularly when you look at in  personal development  the fact that there's an enormous  opportunity for female voices and  they're lacking you know I want to see  more and more and more women